on
le contrôle tout est une question de
contrôler toutes les dictatures
partagent la même obsession
et il est important de se rappeler que
c'est un schéma qui
qui se répète continuellement
à
le contrôle
est ce que tu vas me dire ce que tu as
tout est une question de contrôle allez
voir qui est qui est ce que tu pas c'est
un schéma qui il fait la même voie que
toi
il était co piquant
qui se répète continuellement sais
vraiment pas quoi tu parles
scrutez c'est très bien je vous avais
prévenu
tu es mon seul enfant et moi d'un seul
maire qu'est ce qui se passe et je veux
pas recommencer
est ce que tu me marre
je vais le rappeler pourquoi tu t'es mis
à marcher
c'était pas une bonne idée
le contrôle mais si je faisais ma femme
tout est une question de contrôle